il ya eu un dossier dans le dossier en
fait vous avez traité de nazi un
syndicat de police je vous avoue que moi
je suis très choquée je suis pas le seul
nous sommes des millions à être choqués
on peut pas comparer des policiers
français
un régime qui a planifié l'extermination
de six millions de personnes
est ce que vous regrettez ces propos je
l'aurais je les regrette
ray le jour où on sera capable de
regretter ce qu'on va faire moi est un
ensemble des mutilés de france
on rappelle que vous avez perdu un oeil
en janvier 2019 aujourd'hui un tir de l
bd dans tout ce qui est médiatique on
peut s'insurger sur un mot nazi chose
que je combats je rappelle que j'ai fait
état de ce que j'ai pu vivre est ce que
ma famille a pu vivre
auparavant aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
des groupes facebook
animé par des policiers ou là vous avez
des propos nazis
quand vous arrivez sur des
manifestations vous voyez des tatouages
sur des policiers à connotation nazie
que vous voyez des logos scratch et à
connotation nazie faut bien mettre un
moment donné des maux maintenant je
tiens à préciser que ce n'est pas un
tweet c'est une réponse à un tweet
d'accord que c'est une réponse que je
mets par une colère parce que ça fait un
an et demi que je passe mon temps main
le tweet à l'écran l'a insultée d'accord
il ya moins d'une semaine le même
syndicat c'est permet de me traiter de
fond de cuve j'ai pas entendu aucun
média venir réagir par rapport à ça l'a
toujours est il que la de l'intérieur et
si des balles étaient vides et de
cyclope
mais c'est moi qu'on insulte c'est
l'ensemble des michele je pense qu'on a
su alors comment vous prenez le fait que
le ministre de l'intérieur porte plainte
contre eux voient un petit buzz
voilà on va parler d'autre chose en
attendant et qui ont évité de parler du
12 septembre de la colère des français a
parlé du 12 septembre heure même venu à
l'échelle gel de la communication
gouvernementale on a bien compris qu un
moment donné de pouvoir détourner le
sujet voilà moi ce que j'ai fait au
final dans ce tweet
oui c'est de m'attaquer à une certaine
personne qui se trouve derrière un
compte twitter
moi c'est mon nom un jérôme rodriguez
lui qui est la personne qui a écrit ce
tweet qu'est ce que ça veut dire se
cacher derrière un compte
vous êtes tous là sur différents débats
chaque fois vous matt de savoir qui
écrit les tweets vous êtes les premières
victimes des saloperies qu'on peut
rassurer sur internet
moi ça fait un an et demi que je suis du
cyber harcèlement de la part de troll
comme on a l'habitude de les appeler de
la part de gens à l hérault m mais la
part de il y en a
j'ai re ça n'arrangera l'arrangent
monsieur de l'eau on a eu des
discussions ça n'arrange rien moi quand
je suis dans la rue vous avez les
gardiens de la paix les policiers
municipaux avec qui j'ai des échanges
on est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
mais on a des échanges correct et
cordiaux civilisé d'accord vous avez les
crs dans la manif certains m'ont violée
audriel et de dons dire connard et puis
vous avez la brave on va péter le
deuxième à rodrigues prépare toi qui
s'insurgent de ça aujourd'hui je me
baladais d'une caméra tous les jours que
dieu fasse de la peur du contrôle
d'identité
si contrôle en deux heures 135 euros
d'un monde une journée en garde à vue
aujourd'hui ça c'est mon garde-fous elle
lâché un nouveau pourquoi
bien entendu j'arrive sur une manif ça
crépite rodriguez dont tous les talkie
walkie je voudrais juste rappeler une
chose d'accord juste rappeler une chose
le 27 janvier
je suis tu je suis sur mon lit d'hôpital
j'ai mon oeil dans la main j'appelle au
calme
j'appelle à la paix début 2019 je suis
le premier à parler des suicides
inquiétant qui avait dans la police que
monsieur n'à manoir m'en soit témoin un
syndicalisme de chez vigie je n'ai
jamais été anti flics
j'ai demandé l'autre jour j'ai été
interviewé par une radio qui m'a dit
qu'est ce que vous voudriez bien si j'ai
la possibilité de rencontrer le policier
qui m'a tiré dessus parce qu'il
paraîtrait peut-être un peu inouïe de
pouvoir avoir un échange et le
comprendre pourquoi on en arrive à ça
c'est pas une exacerbée au vis-à-vis de
la police moi j'ai été encore au
commissariat parce qu on me menace de
mort je réponds par des menaces de mort
c'est comme mon nez je craque
j'ai le droit je vous savez le côté
coeur le monopole du coeur comme
disaient les ait un jeu convaincant
je fini par craquer mois par pans de
murs tout au commissariat et je suis
tombé sur une brigadier correct
sympathique à qui on a pu avoir un
échange construit elle m'a écouté bah ça
c'est ma police ça c'est la police du
quotidien de l'ensemble des français
ceux qui sont proches de la population
et qui sont à même de pouvoir aider la
police ne vous inquiétez pas on va
beaucoup parler du 12e temps mais je
veux évidemment à voir la réaction de
bruno pomart alors présenté comme un
ancien du raid qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ce que vient de dire gérer on a
eu déjà des débats sur les plateaux avec
jérôme rodrigues c'est un usurpateur je
redresse
il tente de récupérer ce mouvement gilet
jaune qui est un qui est en train de
mourir et qui est mort d'ailleurs
puisqu'on entend plus parler depuis
longtemps donc il avait besoin de faire
du buzz mais car il traite
l'administration à laquelle j'ai
appartenu pendant 36 heures de nazis
je sais pas s'il connaît l'histoire de
notre pays jérôme rodriguez je pense que
c'est laid outrageant pour la france je
l'air à régler tout à l'heure c'est en
effet outre annulé sa il a remis dans le
contexte
oui mais non je ne soutiens jérôme
roulet robin hobb mais changeront peut
pas se permettre d'utiliser un terme
tard et vous pouvez être contre l'état
contre mini serre intérieure contre la
police si vous voulez non on n'utilisait
pas ce film ce type de 2,2 terme tout
simplement quand on sait en plus que la
police à près de 27 suicides ces
derniers temps je pense que c'est quand
même assez déplacés et je pense que
jérôme rodriguez le 12
donc ça me dit vous tromper totalement
parce que le mouvement gilet jaune à mon
avis vous avez fini par le tuer toutes
les têtes de liste que vous étiez avec
drouet et autres vous avez joué votre
propre carte les hommes et les autres et
vous avez complètement dénaturé ce ce
mouvement qui avec avait du sens et qui
avait du sens parce qu'il y avait moi je
suis élu du territoire durable donc je
connais un petit peu les problématiques
des gens pauvres dans le milieu rural et
je peux vous assurer qu'avec le fait que
les médias vous ai donné beaucoup
beaucoup de de l'ouverture effectivement
ça vous a fait péter les plombs
et voilà et on est parti sur une espèce
de jeu comme ça et vous jouez avec la
population avec ces pauvres gens
effectivement que vous étiez censés
défendre au début et je trouve que c'est
pathétique